much more call 1 808 31 37 100.
The Biden 2024 playbook appears
to be railing against
Republicans over entitlements.
Some Republicans want medicare
and social security sunset. A
lot of Republicans. Their dream
is to cut social security.
Medicare that's a Republican
dream. I'm their nightmare
Republican gonna threaten the
gut and eliminate these
programs. But CNN's K file team
has discovered that the
president once held the
positions that he is now
ridiculing like raising the
retirement age. Here is then
senator Biden in 1987. The year
2010. We are going to change the
retirement age for social
security. You cannot retire at
age 65. Have to be 65 years and
three months old. And the year
2012. 60 years 65 years and six
months. In the year literally.
Raise incrementally. Retired.
Until you reach your entire on
it between six. 87. CNN's Andrew
Kaczynski leads up the K file
unit, and he's joining us live.
So Andrew. That clip was from
1987. But you all were able to
uncover many more examples of
president Biden, then senator
Biden proposing changes to
entitlement. Yeah that's right.
So Biden is attacking and the
white house are attacking
Republicans for positions that
he once held on social security
. We just heard that clip where
he talked about wanting to raise
the retirement age in the 19
eighties. That's something he
said repeatedly. But it actually
goes beyond that. Take for
instance, his attacks on Rick
Scott and this sunset
legislation now sunsetting
basically means that program
will get authorized for
something like four years. And
then if it's not reauthorized,
they don't fund it anymore.
That's hence for the term sunset
comes from now. Biden introduced
a bill in 1975 that did the
exact same thing. It's sunset
all federal legislation without
exemptions for social security
and medicare. And what's
interesting about this? Is
Biden's bill to do this. This
sunset legislation was the first
ever of its kind. We just saw on
the screen where he was
basically boasting about how he
sort of almost invented this
concept of sunsetting at the
federal level, and what's
interesting about his attacks
now on Rick's gotten Republicans
as we saw Rick Scott. Put an
exemption specifically for
entitlement programs into his
bill. Biden himself actually did
the same thing in 1978. He had
another sunset bill that he
signed on, and this one
specifically also put in
exemptions for social security
and medicare. But you know, it
also even goes beyond that.
We've seen Biden ah, over the
course of his career. Talk about
wanting to put, um you know,
medicare or being open to
putting medicare social
security. Things like that on
the table in negotiations. Take
a listen to this clip from 2005
, where he talks about even
possibly being open to benefit
cuts. Raising the cap, raising
the retirement age for people
who are now 30 years old raising
, um the tax and social security
cutting benefits. They're all
things that have to be
discussed. Quite frankly.
Alright Andrew Kaczynski. Thank
you very much for all of that. I
want to read the white house
statement to you. President
Biden has publicly pledged to
veto any plan that cut social
security or medicare benefits or
raises taxes on Americans making
less than $400,000 a year. That
is his position today, so
Francesca. That was then this is
now and that is basically what
they told me. Also that was then
this was now that this was 50
years ago when he first proposed
that 1975 legislation and that
that is not part of his current
plan. I mean, at the time we
have to remember that as a
senator from Delaware, Biden was
a moderate. He was seen as a
moderate by all the senators
around him. He was someone who
was trying to work a lot with
Republicans. And so that's what
those close to him have always
told me even when he used to